hello everyone i'm lidon from the
natural language processing group
at microsoft research asia
today today our talk is about uh
large-scale self-supervised training
from language to vision
uh first let's look at the uh definition
of a large-scale self-supervised pro
trainee
first uh the
first large scale means that our data
and our model the size is quite
large
which supports
various
various tasks
and the second
term is self-supervised
which means that the training signal is
from unlabeled data
such as the wikipedia text corpus
or a bunch of codes uh crawled from the
github
and the third uh
then the third term is pre-training uh
it's it's a new paradigm compared with
traditional machine learning methods uh
the the the the paradigm event uh we
first purchased a large scale model uh
on a very big corpus and then we can
function uh the
obtained model
on our desired uh under tasks
so uh so for uh so for summarization uh
there are three uh key elements uh for
the self-supervised per training
the first one is data
the data can can be text coppers can
also be images can be speed speech
can also be called and the second
element is
the model architecture
the motor architecture we can use for
example rest nights we can use the
transformer
architecture
and for the pre-training task
we often use the denoising auto encoding
still training tasks
and we can also use some contrastive
learning style
tasks
with all these three key elements
we got a very
strong training model
first let me introduce our first
work
which is called unified language model
training for natural language
understanding and natural language
generation
as shown in the slide
we use the
we use a unified modeling
based on the transformer network
then based on this based on the unified
modeling
we can use different self-attention
masks to control the access to context
for each word token in different
variants of language models
derivative training and for
different natural language understanding
and generation tasks
after pre-training we can function the
unified model
as a bi-directional encoder or as a
unidirectional decoder or even as a
as an encoder decoder for sequential
sequence learning
uh and
and for the second work uh we can
i would like to introduce
the unified language model v2
which is which also implements the
unified language model for training but
the difference there here is
that
we we propose a pseudo mask language
model to efficiently
implement the unified language multiple
training for
various objectives such as the auto
encoding one or the auto regressive one
or partially auto regressive one
we with such uh powerful modeling uh
technique uh we can train we can jointly
train these two uh two kinds of
objectives together uh so then we can
function them
on various
downstream tasks
and the third work we try to extend the
unified language modeling to the
multilingual setting
which is called the info xlm
which is a cross-lingual language model
pre-training methods
uh the model is pre-trained on about 100
languages
and with
we use a multi-lingual
corpus as our protruding data and then
we use
we use mask language modeling and
translation language modeling
as the as the training tasks
in addition we propose a cross-lingual
contrastive learning task uh
as a as uh for to retrieve the similar
uh mate across lingual pairs uh from the
large
coppers
well after after such kind of training
we can fine-tune the model uh on just
the english and then try to test
the function model on other languages uh
such cross-lingual airshot transfer is
quite
uh is quite useful
especially when our data set
on the task is quite small
so based on the
the previous work
from from from our group we can
summarize the key observations
from such kind of language for training
first
the key observation is then a
transformer becomes a dominated backbone
network
the observation is quite important
because
we found that when we
when we would like to use a very
large-scale network a transformer is uh
is the current uh
is the current best way to enlarge your
network to memorize the data side uh to
so that we can get a very powerful model
and the second observation is that
generative tasks play the most important
role although we also we also use the
contrastive learning in our info exam
work but we can still notice that
the most
important uh training task is still the
denoising auto encoding still
pre-training
objectives uh such as the mask language
modeling or translation language
modeling
and the
and the third key observation is that
multilingual multilingual is
a multilingual training can be well
handled
by the patron models
which which is also
which also
a very good property for such kind of
training
so a natural research question is that
whether we can translate
the success
from language to vision
for for the first observation
the western transformers
are emerging in the vision community
there are many
related works such as vit deity or swin
transformers uh for working on this
topic and for the second for the second
one uh for the generative training task
uh in the evasion community with
we are still uh
relying on the contrastive learning or
some other uh similarity based uh
[Music]
training methods uh so so the mainstream
algorithm is still not the generative
tasks
and for the third observation we can
find that uh
if we treat the images as a fun language
maybe we can also train we can unify
other training tasks
for the for both
language and
images
so in this talk we would like to talk
talk about our latest work the
which is called bait
uh birth per training of uh image
transformers
so as shown in this slide uh for these
three k elements for the of the
pre-training return to the denoising
auto encoding idea to pressure invasion
transformer which has not been well
studied by the vision community
it's challenging to directly apply birth
to steroid training for image data
first of all
there is no previous exist vocabulary
for vision transformers input unit
which is of image patch so we cannot
simply employ a soft max class fair to
to predict over all possible candidates
for masked pets because the whole search
space is so huge
in contrast
for the language vocabulary such as
words
or the obpe it's well defined and is
auto encoding style per training
a straightforward
alternative way is regarding the task as
a regression problem which predicts the
raw pixels of masks mask the patch
however
such pixel level recover
recovery task tends to waste modeling
capability on pre-training short-range
dependencies and high-frequency details
our goal is to overcome the both issues
for per training of vision transformers
we use we use vision transformer as our
backbone architecture we spill it and
imaging to fix the size patches
and then linearly embed each of them
at position embeddings and feed the
resulting sequence of vectors to a
standard transformer encoder
the encoder contains multiple layers of
transformer blocks
the output vectors of the last layer are
used as the encoded
representations for the image patch
then we can add a soft max class fair to
perform classification by conditioning
on the output vectors
similar to natural language we represent
the image as a sequence of discrete
tokens obtained by an image tokenizer
instead of raw pixels
we learn the image tokenizer via
this discrete variational autoencoder
there are two modules there in uh vision
token uh learning
uh they are tokenizer under the decoder
the tokenizer maps image pixels into
discrete tokens according to a vision
a
visual
code book
and the decoder learns to reconstruct
the input image based on the visual
tokens
because the latent vision
tokens are discrete the model training
is non-differentiable
combos of max
relaxation is employed to train the
model parameters
then we will describe the whole
page per training process the proposal
self-supervised learning task is named
as mask the image modeling
for each input image
it has two views of representations in
our method namely image patch
and the visual tokens the two tabs are
used as the input and output
representations during training
respectively
notice the number of visual tokens and
the number of image patches for one
image are the same
where the correspondence
relations are utilized during training
next we randomly mask approximately 40
percentage
of all the image patches rather than
randomly choosing
patches for the masked positions we
employ block-wise masking our work
which which for which is for each block
we set the minimal number of patches to
16.
then we randomly choose a toy truth and
aspect ratio for the masking block we
repeat the above two steps until
obtaining enough masked patches
the blocking the block-wise masking was
also widely used in
natural language model for training
which is called
which is often called engram masking or
spam masking such mechanism can prove
its short-range dependencies which
improves per training quality as shown
in the slides the corresponding visual
tokens are also masked
we then replace the masked patch with a
learnable embedding
the corrupted image patch are then
fading to the
multiple layer uh transformer the final
hidden states
are regarded as encoded representations
of the input patch
for each
masked position we use the softmax class
fair to predict the corresponding visual
tokens the per training objective is to
maximize the lock like hood of the
cracked visual tokens given the
corrupted images
the masked image modeling task is
greatly inspired by mask language
modeling which is one of the most
successful training objective in natural
language processing
however directly use using pixel level
auto encoding for vision pre-training
push the model to focus on short-range
dependencies and high frequency details
our work overcomes the both issue by
predicting discrete visual tokens which
summarizes the details to high-level
abstractions
ablation studies show that our proposed
method significantly outperforms pixel
level auto encoding
the base
per training can be viewed as
variational auto encoding
training let's consider the evidence
lower bond of recovering the original
image from its corrupted version
the first term denotes
the image tokenizer that obtains visual
tokens and the decodes the original
image given input visual tokens in the
first
protruding stage we obtain the image
a tokenizer as a discrete variational
auto encoder specifically
the first stage minimizes the
reconstruction loss with a uniform
player
and in the second stage
we simplify the q
function to a one point distribution
with the most likely visual tokens then
the second term recovers
recovers the visual tokens based on the
mask the image which is our
mask the image uh modeling pre-training
task it shows that our pro training
process is well spotted by by the
versional auto encoding
theory
and
for our pre-training setup
we train the base model for both uh
verity base size and also for the large
size and we use a code box size with
more than 8k
and our protruding data is from the
image night
but here we didn't use any uh human
label human labels
for the protraining
during the after we preaching the base
model we can append the task layer upon
the transformer and function the
parameters
on downstream tasks like earth
we take image classification and
semantic segmentation as examples in our
presentation it's straightforward to
leverage the pre-training and then
fantunine paradigm on other vision tasks
with our pre-trained model for image
classification tasks
we directly employ
a simple linear class fair as a task
layer
and for the semantic
segmentation task
our decoder our encoder can also be in
the training function in a very similar
way
the table reports
top 1 accuracy on image classification
we compare our methods with vision
transformers trained by randomly
initialized training uh supervised pro
training and the previous uh
self-supervised learning methods all the
compared models are base size except
lgbt has more than one billion
parameters petrini is conduct conducted
on humid net for the comparison
purpose except the vit jft
is pretend on google's in-house
300 million images compared with the
model compared with the model stream by
randomly neutralization we confirmed
that the purchasing base
significantly improves performance on
both data sets
the results also indicates that
bits can greatly reduce the requirement
of annotation efforts but also
improves the performance on imagenet
which shows a very
interesting
property which is
which is quite effective under the rich
resource setting moreover we compare our
method with previous state-of-the-art
self-supervised method for transformer
such as denu and mokul our
post methods out forms previous
self-supervised models on imagenet fan
tuning
train the
between the pre-training tasks of page
and
denote together in a multi-task manner
augmenting uh mask the image modeling
with deno improves semantic segmentation
and all obtains comparable results on
imagenet classification moreover
we found that which is more efficient in
terms of pre-training speed as deno has
two copies of transformer parameters for
self distillation and the multi
crop argumentation
because beta is
is more memory efficient we can use a
much larger batch size to food to fully
utilize gpu cards in practice
we further scale up based to the large
size
the results also verify
uh verifies that date hungry issue of
visual transformers
where
when training from scratch uh we can
finance the base uh we can finance the
the
vit from scratch performances
is worse
compared large to the base in comparison
the benefits of scaling up bait from
base to large are greater than
supervised per training the results
suggest that bait tends to help more for
extremely
larger models especially when labeled
data are insufficient to conduct
supervised pre-training for such large
models
we also compared the converge
convergency curves
of the training from scratch and
pre-training and centurion paradigms
with fundamentals fan-tuning base not
only achieves better performance but all
but also converging much faster than
training the eit from scratch
moreover fan tuning baits can reach
reasonable numbers within very few
epochs
then we evaluate page on semantic
segmentation benchmark
by opening a task layer based on upper
net we can function the base backbone on
the in the task
our model achieves sleep they are
performance even compared with previous
strong methods
we conduct ablation studies to analysis
the contributions of each component in
bit first we oblate block-wise masking
by randomly sample mask the positions we
find that block-wise masking is
beneficial on both tasks especially on
semantic segmentation
second we oblate the usage of virtual
tokens by predicting the real pixels of
masked patches
the purchasing task becomes a pixel
level regression problem to recovery
mask the patch
our proposed mask the image modeling
task significantly outperforms naive
pixel levels encoding
the results indicates that the
prediction of visual tokens is a key
ingredient of bit
first we
we try to uplate the usage of visual
tokens and block wise masking together
we found that block waste masking is
even more helpful for pixel level auto
encoding which relieves the suffering of
short distance dependency
fourth we compare bits with different
training steps per training the model
much longer can further improve
performance on downstream tasks
we show them
the self-attention mechanism in place
can separate objects even though our
our protranian doesn't rely
on any manual adaptation at all the
probing images are taken from the ms
coppers to avoid appearing in the
training data
we
we plot the self-attention map for
different reference points within an
image the visualization are produced by
attention scores computed via query key
products in the last layer for each
reference point we use the corresponding
patch as a query and show which patch it
attends to after
training
it learns to distinguish semantic
regions using self-attention heads even
without any task specific supervision
the property partially indicates the
reason why bt is able to help downstream
tasks such knowledge acquired by base
potentially improves the generalization
ability
of phantom models is especially on
small-scale data sites
our contributions are summarized as
follows
first we propose a mask the image
modeling task to pre-treat vision
transformers in a self-supervised manner
we also prevent a theoretical
explanation from the perspective of
variational autoencoder
second we
pretrimpate and conduct
extensive functioning experiments on
downstream tasks such as image
classification and semantic segmentation
third we present then the self-attention
mechanism of
self-supervised base learns to
distinguish
semantic regions and the object's
boundaries although without any human
notation
our code and the patron models can be
downloaded from
from this
link thanks for your attention